stellen sie sich vor sie wollen us
präsidenten oder präsident werden das
braucht es für eine kandidatur
sie sind mindestens 35 jahre alt und
gebürtig us staatsbürger sie brauchen
ein großes team aus helfern und
sponsoren denn der wahlkampf in den usa
ist aufwendig und teuer
schon neun monate vorher geht der
wahlkampf los in der eigenen partei mit
den vorwahlen aber nicht alle
parteimitglieder stimmen über sie ab
sondern delegierte wie viele dieser
delegierten sie in jedem bundesstaat
überzeugen müssen ist eine komplizierte
rechnung dazu haben demokraten und
republikaner noch mal eigene regeln
in den meisten bundesstaaten finden so
genannte primaries statt hier können
alle parteimitglieder in wahllokalen
oder per briefwahl abstimmen
manchmal auch parteilose bürger oder
sogar mitglieder anderer parteien die
sich vorher registrieren mussten in
einigen staaten und regionen wird auf
wahlversammlungen entschieden so
genannten core courses dort müssen sie
und ihre helfer um jeden einzelnen
wähler werben
danach wird per handzeichen oder
stimmzettel abgestimmt leisten sie genug
überzeugungsarbeit ihr wohl
entscheidender tag der super tuesday
super weil an diesem dienstag viele
vorwahlen gleichzeitig stattfinden und
40 prozent der delegiertenstimmen können
sie sich an diesem tag sichern
vor allem in großen bundesstaaten wie
kalifornien und texas
insgesamt gibt es diesmal 22 vorwahl
tage in 50 bundesstaaten und gebieten
am ende brauchen sie mehr als die hälfte
der delegierten hinter sich auf dem
nominierungsparteitag im sommer
vielleicht helfen ihnen dort auch
delegierte von anderen kandidaten die
bis dahin aufgegeben haben oder so
genannte super delegierte ihrer partei
wenn sie hier gewinnen sind sie kandidat
ihrer partei noch nicht präsidentin oder
präsident denn erst jetzt beginnt der
wirklich entscheidende wahl kampf ums
weiße haus